.
Ich habe sehr viel Energie
und Passion.
Das wurde mir in die Wiege gelegt.
Als ich ankam, hat mir
unser Generalsekretär gesagt:
"Mach es doch einfach so:
Luege, lose, laufe!"
Sich schnell umzustellen,
ist mir nicht neu.
Das Interesse der Schweiz
an einer friedlichen Welt
steht schon in der Verfassung,
die nachhaltige Entwicklung auch.
Sie ist die erste Frau
an der Spitze der DEZA.
Mit so viel Drive ist wohl keiner
ihrer Vorgänger gestartet.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Ich brauche das fast jeden Tag,
um mein Hirn in Gang zu bringen,
v.a. am Morgen.
Es ist auch sehr gut für die Psyche.
Ich denke, meine Mitarbeiter merken,
wenn ich drei oder vier Tage
keinen Sport gemacht habe.
Es ist also für alle gut,
wenn ich das mache.
Es ist sicher toll, wenn man das
mit dem Sohn machen kann.
Am Morgen mit Mami Sport
machen zu können, ist supergeil.
Ja, es ist gut.
Er ist nicht immer wach am Morgen,
aber ... Er ist v.a. schnell.
Sie kann noch gut mithalten
und ist noch sehr sportlich.
Das ist der jüngere Sohn.
Ich habe noch einen älteren,
der auch sehr sportlich ist.
Es ist cool,
mit den Söhnen Sport zu machen.
Vor ihrer Berufskarriere hat es
Patricia Danzi als Siebenkämpferin
bis an die Olympischen Spiele
von Atlanta geschafft.
Wenn ich mir ein Ziel gesteckt habe,
habe ich es meistens erreicht.
Ich habe gemerkt,
dass ich schnell lernen kann.
Aber das konnten andere auch.
Ich hatte vielleicht mehr Ausdauer
als der Durchschnitt.
Und ich konnte mich sehr gut
auf etwas fokussieren
und wenn es sein musste,
mehr Leistung bringen -
sozusagen auf Abruf.
Wenn es wirklich zählt
oder wirklich sein muss,
konnte ich mich darauf verlassen,
dass aus irgendeiner Energiequelle,
von der ich nicht genau weiss,
woher sie kommt, noch mehr Energie
und meistens gute oder
sogar bessere Ideen hervorkommen.
Der Bundesrat holt Patricia Danzi,
die Frau,
die sieben Sprachen spricht,
vom Internationalen Roten Kreuz
in die Direktion
für Entwicklung und Zusammenarbeit.
Sie ist die erste Frau
an der Spitze der DEZA.
Sie hat sich im Selektionsverfahren
als die beste Kandidatin erwiesen.
(Italienisch)
Vielen Dank für Ihr Vertrauen.
Ich freue mich sehr,
diesen Posten übernehmen zu dürfen
und ich garantiere, mich voll
und ganz dafür zu engagieren.
Die Frau, die antritt,
um Not und Armut zu lindern,
Demokratie zu fördern
und Menschenrechte einzuhalten,
trifft auf
eine gigantische Gesundheitskrise.
Man weiss nicht genau,
wie es ausgeht.
Das ist bei vielen Krisen
auch der Fall,
aber dieses Mal
betrifft es die ganze Welt.
Sagt man "Corona",
kann sich der Bauer in Afghanistan
mit dem Banker in New York
über das gleiche Thema unterhalten.
Das ist sicher ganz speziell.
Im ersten Amtsjahr bestimmt die
Pandemie Inhalte und Form der Arbeit.
Hello. Nice to meet you.
- Thanks for being here.
Let's go inside and talk.
Treffen, wie hier
in der Genfer Mission, sind selten.
Wherever you want to sit ...
Maybe you want a view.
Danke fürs Kommen.
- Danke, dass Sie sich Zeit nehmen.
Hier eine Karte für Sie.
- Oh, thank you.
Gratuliere zur neuen Position.
- Danke.
Ich freue mich, Sie zu treffen.
Wir haben viel gemeinsam.
Ja, mehr als wir glauben.
And more going forward.- Yes.
Austausch
mit internationalen Organisationen
ist wichtiger Bestandteil
von Patricia Danzis Arbeit.
GCERF z.B. widmet sich
der Terrorismusprävention.
Wenn es keine Perspektiven für junge
Leute gibt, sie keinen Job haben,
keine Perspektiven für ihre Familien
sehen, etwas aufzubauen,
kann es sein - das gilt
noch lange nicht für alle -,
dass sie sich Organisationen
zuwenden, die das versprechen.
Es ist wichtig -
die Organisation GCERF macht das -,
Alternativen für junge Leute
aufzubauen,
damit sie sich nicht terroristischen
Organisationen zuwenden müssen,
damit sie eine Zukunft für sich
und ihre Familie sehen.
Good morning, good morning.
Im Stundentakt geben sich Vertretende
verschiedener Organisationen
die Klinke in die Hand.
Der Klimawandel und seine Folgen
gehören aktuell zu den Schwerpunkten
der Entwicklungszusammenarbeit
der DEZA.
Ich bevorzuge physische Treffen.
Man kommt ganz anders in Kontakt.
There's an emotion
that comes with it.
Von überall auf der Welt
erreichen die studierte
Umwelt- und Agrarwissenschaftlerin
ähnliche Erfahrungsberichte.
Wir hatten noch nie so viel
Trockenheit oder so wenig Regen.
Oder noch nie
so viel Regen auf einmal,
noch nie so viele Krankheiten,
noch nie so viel überhaupt.
Fast jeder
kann auf irgendeine Art und Weise
von extremen Lagen berichten
und erzählen.
D.h., dass der Planet als solches
in einer extremen Situation ist.
A bit closer to the flags.
Thank you very much.
- Thank you.
Sie waren auch Olympionikin?
Das ist lange her.
- Man sieht es immer noch.
Im Laufschritt geht es über Mittag
zum Hauptsitz
des Internationalen Roten Kreuzes.
25 Berufsjahre auf der ganzen Welt
verbinden Patricia Danzi
mit dem IKRK -
und viele Freundschaften.
Herr Stillhart, hoi. Freut mich.
Wie muss man sich begrüssen?
- Wir dürfen so. Hoi.
Bist du fit?
- Ja.
Du siehst gut aus
mit einem richtigen Bart.
Dominik Stillhart ist ein Weg-
begleiter der ersten Stunde im IKRK.
Auf ihrer ersten Mission in Bosnien
haben sie sich kennengelernt.
Ich bin zwei Tage in Genf.
Heute können wir die Meetings zum
Glück noch machen. Morgen dann ...
Was für Meetings habt ihr?
Mit den UN-Organisationen, denen wir
Geld geben. Geneva International.
Alle die, die Geld bekommen
und noch mehr wollen.
Wir sollten nach Maputo, New York,
Brüssel und Albanien gehen.
Dann sagten wir:
"Nach Genf können wir sicher."
Alles abgesagt.
Jetzt machen wir es virtuell.
Hast du deine Leute
alle mal gesehen?- Nein.
Konntest du gar nie ins Büro?
- Doch, ins Büro ging ich immer.
Ich habe ein grosses.
Aber ich habe nie alle gesehen.
So Town-Hall-Meetings
mit allen zusammen - never.
Was mich bei ihr
immer extrem beeindruckt hat,
seit ich sie das erste Mal
in den 90er-Jahren
in Bosnien getroffen habe:
Sie ist einfach immer extrem ruhig.
Man hört nie ein lautes Wort.
Sie strahlt
eine ganz natürliche Autorität aus.
Das hat ihr extrem viel genützt
in dieser Arbeit und mit dem Druck,
dem wir auch viel ausgesetzt sind
in einer humanitären Organisation.
Sie ist einfach extrem belastbar.
Was sie alles
unter einen Hut bringt,
ist wirklich ausserordentlich.
Es fährt immer ein, was einem die
Leute sagen oder auch nicht sagen,
wenn man ihnen in die Augen schaut,
und wenn man sieht, wie es ist.
Das sind viele Eindrücke,
die bleiben.
Es gibt sicher eine gewisse Dosis
an Bescheidenheit.
Dass man sich nicht wichtig nimmt.
Ich hoffe, das habe ich nie gemacht.
Dass es einem hauptsächlich
um die Sache geht,
und man versucht,
kleine Verbesserungen zu bringen,
dafür aber stetig und jeden Tag.
Ich finde es sensationell,
dass jemand mit dieser Erfahrung
jetzt die Schweiz
auf diesem Niveau vertreten kann.
Was ich einfach extrem gut finde,
v.a. in der heutigen Zeit, ist,
dass Patricia auch in verschiedenen
Kulturen verankert ist.
Für die Arbeit, die wir machen
und sie jetzt bei der DEZA macht,
ist das einfach total wichtig.
Sie hat einen ganz speziellen Zugang
zu vielen verschiedenen Leuten.
Das ist gerade in dieser Arbeit
extrem wichtig.
Die Eltern haben Patricia Danzi gutes
Rüstzeug mit auf den Weg gegeben.
Ihr nigerianischer Vater
ist in Fribourg Doktorand
in Rechtswissenschaften,
ihre Mutter angehende Sekundar-
lehrerin, als sie zur Welt kommt.
Von der Mutter
hat sie das humanitäre Engagement,
vom Vater das diplomatische Geschick.
Das war in Moskau.
Aufgewachsen in der Region Zug,
wird Patricia Danzi
oft auf ihre Herkunft angesprochen.
Ihre Hautfarbe
ist schon in früher Kindheit Thema.
An meinem ersten Tag im Kindergarten
wurde gesagt,
es habe zwei Kinder,
die anders seien.
"Seid nett zu ihnen!"
Ich habe mich umgesehen
und mich gefragt, wer das sei.
Alle haben mich angeschaut.
Da merkte ich,
ich könnte gemeint sein.
Dann war da noch
ein Junge mit Behinderung.
Er war der Zweite von den beiden,
die sie meinte.
Da fuhr mir das zum ersten Mal ein.
Aber ich hatte nicht das Gefühl,
in einer Opferrolle zu sein.
Ich habe immer versucht,
in jeder Situation -
ob wegen der Hautfarbe,
ob als Frau oder als Mädchen -
das Positive zu sehen
und auch zu machen.
Das Positive als Frau war ...
... dass man im Berufsleben
früher aufgefallen ist.
In der Arbeitswelt
hatte man einen Vorteil,
wenn Diversität gefragt war -
und die ist immer noch gefragt.
Da hatte man eher einen Vorteil.
Nach zehn Monaten endlich
die erste Auslandreise im neuen Amt.
Mit dabei: ein Reporterteam
der "Schweizer Illustrierten".
COVID bestimmt den Reiseplan.
Super, dann sind wir vollständig.
Hast du dein Testresultat erhalten?
Es ist verschlüsselt.
Beratend an der Seite:
Ruth Huber, Chefin des Bereichs
Ostzusammenarbeit der DEZA.
* Ruhige Musik *
20 Std. Busreise nach Sarajevo
liegen vor ihr.
Es ist eine Rückkehr -
an den Ort ihrer Hochzeit und ihres
ersten Einsatzes als IKRK-Delegierte.
Am Wochenende
wurde mir ein wenig klar,
was all die Emotionen bedeuteten,
als ich als junge IKRK-Delegierte
das erste Mal nach Bosnien reiste.
Es gab sehr viele Emotionen
in diesen fast 2 1/2 Jahren
in diesem Kontext.
Nicht nur in Bosnien, sondern
auch in Serbien und Montenegro.
Ja, das ist speziell, sicher.
Man sagt immer,
dass etwas von der ersten Mission
als IKRK-Delegierte zurückbleibt.
Ich bin gespannt,
was das alles auslöst.
Aber ich bin auch gespannt zu sehen,
wie es nach 24 Jahren aussieht.
* Ruhige Musik *
Immer wenn ich auf eine Reise gehe,
versuche ich, ein Buch zu lesen,
welches von dem Land, dem Kontext
erzählt.
Am besten einen Roman, der mich
ein wenig in die Stimmung versetzt
und anders ist als die Berichte,
die man sonst so liest.
Ich bin noch nicht sehr weit
und hoffe, ich kann es fertig lesen.
Es handelt von Leuten,
die versuchen,
über den Krieg hinwegzukommen,
die eine Zukunft suchen
und bei denen die Menschlichkeit
in den Vordergrund rückt,
obwohl sehr viel Schlechtes
existiert.
Ah, super, das ist tipptopp.
Mehr benötige ich nicht.
Ich würde gerne den Bus fahren,
aber das darf ich wohl nicht.
Er ist ein bisschen gross.
- Er ist gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Die Reise führt durch Italien,
Slowenien und Kroatien nach Bosnien.
Unterwegs immer wieder Fahrerwechsel.
Auf dem Balkan rücken Kriegs-
vergangenheit und Migrationskrise
in den Vordergrund.
Dobro jutro.
- (Beide) Dobro jutro.
Guten Morgen.
Eine Mitarbeiterin der Botschaft
empfängt die Reisegruppe.
Auf der anderen Seite haben sie
Migranten in Lastwagen gefunden.
Eben jetzt am Morgen.
- Jetzt?
Was habt ihr gefunden?
- Migranten in den Lastwagen.
An der Grenze?
- Ja.
* Düstere Klänge *
Der Krieg in den 90er-Jahren
hat Spuren bis in die Gegenwart
hinterlassen.
Patricia Danzi erinnert sich an
die Situation kurz nach Kriegsende.
Was mir einfuhr,
war diese Zerstörung einer Stadt,
bombardierte Häuser,
und in den ersten paar Tagen mit der
Bevölkerung das kollektive Trauma,
das viele Leute hatten.
Das war etwas, das wahrscheinlich
bei vielen Leuten noch weitergeht.
Wir sehen dann ein paar Projekte,
die das angehen.
Es ist nicht einfach fertig,
wenn der Krieg fertig ist,
sondern es geht lange,
um das zu verarbeiten.
Nach 20 Std. Reise:
Ankunft im Hotel in der Hauptstadt.
Hey. Good to see you,
good to see you.
After so, so many years.
And I knew I'll have time ...
Mustafa Sarajlic und Patricia Danzi
haben vor 25 Jahren zusammen
für das IKRK in Gorazde gearbeitet.
Als wir zusammengearbeitet haben,
hatten wir noch keine Familie.
Und jetzt sind die Kinder
beinahe erwachsen.
It's so nice to see you.
Als ich nach Sarajevo kam,
warst du schon hier.
Wir machten die Fahrprüfung.
- Genau.
Am selben Tag.
- Im selben Auto.
Im selben Auto. Und ich sagte:
"Ich arbeite in Gorazde."
Und du sagtest: "Ich auch."
- Was für ein Zufall!
Yes, maybe.
Wir sind da.
Kua Sarajlic.
- Ja.
Du hast vieles selber gemacht,
nicht wahr?- Ja.
Schön, euch alle zu treffen.
Du bist so gross.
Und wir werden immer kleiner.
Patricia, wie geht es dir?
- Mir geht es gut.
Gehst du noch joggen?
- Ja.
Als wir heute angekommen sind,
haben die Journalisten
nicht gemerkt,
dass ich mit dem Springseil
auf der Terrasse war -
nur, um mich zu bewegen.
Lasst uns über Gorazde sprechen!
Patricia
war sehr bekannt in Gorazde,
weil sie jeden Morgen joggen ging.
Jeden Morgen. Nobody else
in that small place was running.
Sie war eine Athletin.
Wir waren fasziniert,
dass sie Mitglied des
Olympischen Teams der Schweiz war.
Wir waren jung
und aus einem kleinen Dorf,
das gerade
aus dem Krieg gekommen ist.
Das war schon speziell.
Speziell für uns.
Aber im Grunde ist es nichts
im Vergleich zu dem,
was wir in der Folge realisierten,
wie gross Herz und Seele dieser Frau
sind,
die damals
noch Patricia Nadler hiess.
* Ruhige Musik *
I have some other ones.
This is my mother preparing Borek.
Er hat keine richtige Schwester,
aber hätte er eine,
müsste das Patricia sein.
Deine Grossmutter
hat mich sozusagen adoptiert.
Sie lässt dir ausrichten,
sie vermisse dich sehr.- Thank you.
Der junge Mustafa.
Das ist ungefähr zu der Zeit,
als wir uns kennengelernt haben.
A bit later.
Das ist in deinem Büro.
Later I worked in there.
Ich muss dir dieses Foto zeigen.
* Lachen *
Er war mein Trauzeuge
bei unserer Hochzeit in Gorazde.
Genau. Wir waren 23 Jahre jünger.
Ich habe ihn in Sarajevo
kennengelernt.
Er war auch Delegierter.
Und wir haben in Gorazde geheiratet.
Die mussten die Formulare
erst finden.
Die Behörden hatten immer noch
die jugoslawischen Formulare.
Nach dem Krieg waren wir die Ersten,
die in Gorazde mit den neuen
Formularen geheiratet hatten.
Mhm.
* Ruhige Musik *
Ihr erster Einsatz
hat eine starke Verbindung
zu Land und Leuten geschaffen.
Die Wunden des Krieges
sind in der Region bis heute präsent.
Die Arbeitslosigkeit ist riesig,
die Abwanderung gross.
Insbesondere die junge Generation
ist desillusioniert.
Die DEZA unterstützt gezielt
Projekte, die helfen,
alte Strukturen und Hindernisse - wie
etwa die Korruption - zu überwinden.
Indem man etwas anderes vorlebt
und man junge Leute dazu motiviert,
für eine Sache zu arbeiten und
sich nicht dem System unterzuordnen.
Jungen Menschen
eine Perspektive bieten -
das will dieses Start-up-Unternehmen.
Lassen Sie mich
die Herausforderungen schildern!
Alle interessieren sich dafür,
wie wir damit umgehen und wie wir
die Probleme lösen wollen.
Die Jugend von heute
hat die Hoffnung verloren.
Wir glauben, wenn die Jugend hier
eine faire Möglichkeit hat ...
... sich zu entwickeln,
Jobs zu finden, Jobs zu machen,
werden wir
eine neue Hoffnung kriegen.
Dann haben wir eine neue Zukunft
für Bosnien-Herzegowina.
Mit der Wirtschaft
Bosnien-Herzegowinas
geht es auch ein Vierteljahrhundert
nach dem Krieg kaum aufwärts.
Über zwei Millionen Menschen
sind seither abgewandert.
Dort kommt man
in eine enge Schlucht runter
und hat richtig das Gefühl,
man fahre in einen Kessel.
Man konnte sich vorstellen,
wie das alles völlig zerstört war.
Doch eine neue Generation
weckt Hoffnung.
Diese jungen Menschen
setzt die DEZA in einem Projekt als
Botschafterinnen und Botschafter ein.
Die Schweizer Botschaft hat
uns Junge als Erste ernst genommen
und gemerkt,
dass wir konstruktive Ideen haben.
Wir sind eine neue Generation,
die sich keine Grenzen mehr setzt.
Es gibt Menschen,
die zuhören und sagen,
dass wir Jungen recht haben.
Es ist eine grossartige Chance, in
diesen Prozess eingebunden zu sein
und unser Zusammenleben
zu verbessern.
Vielleicht sollten wir alle
die Grenzen überschreiten,
die wir uns gesetzt haben.
So können wir unser Land
vorwärtsbringen.
Diesen Tatendrang und diese
Zuversicht will die DEZA nutzen.
Ab in eine neue Zukunft.
Ich wollte schon immer
im Sommer Bobschlitten fahren.
Beinahe 30 Projekte
unterstützt die DEZA in Bosnien,
fördert demokratische Strukturen
oder die Gleichberechtigung
der Geschlechter.
Engagements,
die über Jahre gepflegt werden.
Die Kriegsvergangenheit
zu überwinden,
dieses Ziel bleibt im Fokus.
In diesem Psychiatriezentrum
investiert die DEZA in die
psychische Gesundung der Bevölkerung.
Es geht um die Leute,
die den Krieg erlebt haben,
die das Kollektivtrauma erlebt haben
als Familie, als Dorf, als Stadt.
Man kann sich gegenseitig
nur sehr schwer da rausholen.
Es braucht Hilfe von aussen,
von Psychologen, Psychiatern,
von einer ganzen Equipe,
und die gab es nicht.
Auch während des Krieges nicht.
Darum die Unterstützung.
Es geht nicht nur um diejenigen,
die es erlebt haben,
sondern auch um die Nächsten.
Wenn man Mutter oder Vater ist
und den Krieg erlebt hat,
überträgt man das
auf die nächsten Generationen.
D.h.,
ein solches Trauma ist nie fertig.
Es gab auch Verhaltens-
und Persönlichkeitsstörungen,
Alkoholprobleme
und auch affektive Störungen.
Das hat sich eigentlich auf
die nächste Generation übertragen.
* Ruhige Musik *
Um zur nächsten Station an der Grenze
zu gelangen,
ist es Zeit, Abschied zu nehmen.
Bon voyage.
Bye. Tschau, tschau.
Die Reise geht weiter
an die EU-Aussengrenze,
nach Bihac ins Auffanglager Lipa.
Migranten ... Ja, vermutlich schon.
Es sieht so aus.
Lipa hat in den vergangenen Jahren
traurige Berühmtheit erlangt:
Das Camp war nicht winterfest,
die Unterbringung der Migranten
katastrophal.
Gemeinsam
mit dem Schweizer Botschafter
informiert sich Patricia Danzi
vor Ort über die humanitäre Lage.
Trotz Anwesenheit von lokalen Medien-
und Sicherheitsleuten versucht Danzi,
sich ein möglichst authentisches Bild
zu machen.
Ich hasse es,
wenn die Kameras kommen.
Die Leute fühlen sich ausgestellt.
Das will ich nicht.
Sie sollen sich frei fühlen,
zu reden.
They should come and talk.
Die Migranten kommen mehrheitlich
aus Afghanistan,
Bangladesch und Pakistan.
Sind Sie vom Süden?
- Punjab.
Punjab, okay. Haben Sie
Ihre Familie zurückgelassen?
Sie gingen alleine?
Ich ging alleine, ja.
Eine ziemliche Reise.
Hoffen wir,
dass alles gut wird für Sie.
Viel Glück!
Die Schweiz hat ein Migrations-
abkommen mit Bosnien-Herzegowina.
Es ist immer gut, zu sehen,
wie junge Frauen sich engagieren
und was sie daraus machen.
Deshalb sind wir hier.
Wir arbeiten
für eine bessere Zukunft.- Yes.
Danke für alles, was Sie machen.
- Thank you.
Behalten Sie die Motivation!
And learn.
Sie sind noch recht motiviert.
- Ja, ja.
Das ist schon noch verrückt,
das alles zu sehen -
unter welchen Bedingungen sie leben.
Die jungen Männer
haben bereits eine lange
und beschwerliche Reise hinter sich.
Just continue, please.
First aid first.
DasPersonal
kommt vom Zentrum in Bihac.
Am Wochenende sind es Freiwillige.
On the weekend it's volunteers.
Was ist das Hauptproblem?
- Schmerzen.
Pain?
- Pain.
Sie kommen mit offenen Wunden.
- Vom Fussmarsch?
Von der Polizei
an der kroatischen Grenze.
Oft verarztet das Gesundheitspersonal
Menschen,
die an der Grenze zurückgewiesen,
mit sog. Push-Backs
brutal zurückgestossen wurden.
Wenn Menschen migrieren,
machen sie das nicht freiwillig.
Es gibt einen Grund dafür.
Es sind viele junge Männer,
die irgendwo eine Zukunft suchen.
Es gibt persönliche Schicksale
und Familienschicksale.
Es ist sicher besser organisiert
als vor zwei, drei Monaten.
Das ist sicher mal gut.
Aber das Migrationsproblem
ist immer ein grösseres Problem.
Die Migrationskrise aber
ist ein politisches,
ein gesamteuropäisches Problem.
Ich würde es sehr schätzen,
wenn die Polizei
nicht die ganze Zeit so nahe wäre.
I don't think
there's going to be a problem.
Sie muss mich nicht beschützen.
They don't have to feel responsible
for me.
Maybe you can tell him.
Hello.
- Hello.
Bei der Essensausgabe müssen
die Migranten ihre Ausweise zeigen,
damit sie sich
nicht mehrmals täglich anstellen.
Machen Sie das jeden Tag?
* Sie spricht Bosnisch. *
Ja, COVID-mässig
ist es schon nicht so ...
Nein, es ist nicht so ...
Er hat auch nie richtig geantwortet.
Ich meine, Abstand halten,
Hände waschen, Masken ...
Ich meine,
es ist Hilfe zur Selbsthilfe.
Wir versuchen es.
Sind nicht genügend Masken
vorhanden?
Masken sind schon vorhanden aber ...
- ... sie benützen sie nicht.
But they have access to masks?
- Yes.
Die Einhaltung
von COVID-Schutzmassnahmen
ist nur eines von vielen Problemen
im Auffanglager.
Diese Leute
sind seit Monaten unterwegs,
haben vielleicht schon
ein- bis zweimal probiert,
über die Grenze zu kommen, es hat
vielleicht nicht funktioniert,
ihnen ist v.a. kalt,
sie haben Hunger
und es hat viele Leute
in einem Zelt.
Es sind alles junge Männer.
Dann gibt es Spannungen.
Wir würden gerne schauen,
was sich verbessert hat.
Okay.
Aber nur, wenn es okay ist für Sie.
If not, we won't.
Yes?
Excuse me, listen to me.
Wir haben viele Probleme hier.
Das Wasser ist ein Problem
und die Toiletten
sind ein noch grösseres Problem.
Wie lange sind Sie hier?
Ich bin seit zwei Monaten hier.
- Seit zwei Monaten.
Okay.
Wasser, Toiletten, Essen ...
I hear you.
Wir machen, was wir können.
Wenn man von aussen kommt, ist man
manchmal auch einfach ein Ventil.
Die Leute können sagen,
was alles nicht gut ist.
Wir nehmen das auch auf.
Manchmal können wir etwas machen,
manchmal nicht.
Es geht um eine
würdevolle Behandlung von Menschen,
die vieles auf sich genommen haben.
Ja, Wahnsinn.
Sie sind z.T.
zwei, drei Jahre unterwegs,
bis sie hierhin kommen.
- Ja.
Es ist kein Superlager,
aber im Vergleich zu dem,
wie es war, ist es sicher besser.
D.h., es braucht langfristige,
systemische Änderungen,
damit das Land die Eigenschaften
und Kapazitäten hat,
einen solchen Migrationsstrom
aufzufangen.
Das passiert nicht
von heute auf morgen.
Da braucht es
eine langfristige Zusammenarbeit.
Die haben wir jetzt aufgebaut,
aber es gibt noch viel zu tun.
* Ruhige Musik *
Die Migrationskrise wird die Region
noch länger beschäftigen.
Die Unterstützung der DEZA
ist eine Hilfe,
aber keine Lösung.
Patricia Danzi und die Reisegruppe
verlassen das Land,
um von der Schweiz aus
die Migrationsfrage weiter anzugehen.
* Melancholische Musik *
Ich bin optimistisch, ja.
Anders kann man gar nicht sein,
sonst wird man sofort depressiv.
Das Jahr, das wir hinter uns haben,
hat gezeigt, dass das geht.
Es geht darum,
Prioritäten zu setzen.
Wir können nicht einfach sagen,
das gehe uns nichts an.
Es gibt keine andere Wahl.
Nichts zu machen, ist keine Option.
Herzlich willkommen, Patricia Danzi,
Kolleginnen, die hier mit mir sind.
Geschätzte Mitglieder
dieser Kommission ...
Unter der Leitung von Patricia Danzi
hilft die Schweiz weiterhin mit,
die Probleme in der internationalen
Zusammenarbeit anzupacken.
Aber wir machen das Beste
aus den Umständen, die wir haben.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretype gmbh - 2021